yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master you be lund who is this no name
oops so no name okay let's go with a
classical kind of setup here doing
nothing fancy
I probably yeah exactly wants to go for
the fianchetto we I could have played 94
directly would have been rather than
logical right but it's not it's not not
bad i anything okay let's put the night
on you for just a moment they are but
pancakes and doesn't make much sense hmm
let's gain some space on the queenside
seems seems fairly fairly nice for me I
think maybe a four yeah keep his pawns
fixed on dark squares I'll keep it fixed
this wrong trying to fix them on dark
squares would be the correct way to
describe it
yeah ideally I would ok I would like the
night on c4 this is not not happening
yeah I don't know he's see closing down
things maybe with before then I will
play a fire I guess hmm preventing efore
yeah on e4 I can go F for so that's not
not any kind of problem I can even do
this and on e4 fo but if I looks like a
mistake already well no mistake is too
strong but have form I wonder maybe I
should do this immediately I'll just
bring the Queen over to g6 I can go with
five though maybe even yeah now that
wasn't a very great idea man probably
let's do this
and one now maybe I can take and go
Bishop g5 trying to take the to put the
knight on f6 that that could be good and
that's the interesting idea maybe I can
get a good nights they are to e4 yeah
that's nice
that's nice Jim seems like a good
position from luck okay so check here
right and check with them em with the e
pawn yeah so let's take it
yes Bishop t2 in some situations which
would probably equalize the whole thing
okay let's start with this Knight f6
tricky it's complicated yeah is Roxy to
what a silly move but a good move at
almost it doesn't trap my bishop but
it's close I overlooked Roxy to him with
this traps the bishop have I really
losing this game this is this is crazy
this is crazy he got now come on I
shouldn't start this thing again he
really got totally outplayed here
strategically and I'm rendering this
piece then okay still not so easy due to
his totally uncoordinated pieces here
Knight to c3 probably heave get this in
ah what a shame I just have to be more
precise them and white is in big trouble
with his bed Bishop and so on even this
is not I mean he should win somehow but
it's not completely easy look at how
ridiculous the pieces are f21 I could
have probably had something similar
without being a piece down yeah what
does this move here okay just trying to
bring the King up if i go here he checks
me so let's go here yeah maybe maybe
just rupee one
hmm what is the dr 93 okay 93 look T 4
will be at least two points then okay i
guess i have to do this k so night look
here is not f1 you can you have to go
here
it should be lost but it's no particular
reason to resign it's still it's still a
bit tricky Knight f6 might pick up his
pawns for example okay
that's it's a strongly though that's a
strong move time warning ok check yeah
that's true takes c6 he's just quick out
him so let's do this
okay s III is taking unfortunately
check what the game somehow continuing
and I don't know what that is check hi
I'm Jonathan Poland them come on ya can
offer i'll offer checking or for him and
you're over there don't want to win this
on time check thank you check oh I've
been wondering the Queen it oh yeah okay
that was silly what a silly game but if
I don't blunder the piece that I he's
really completely completely busted I
mean just like that just I just have to
be precise there this is a terrible
position for wide-eyed really did not
see Roxy to this is this is very stupid
cannot cannot believe him that he that
he should be always able to hold that
the computer just gives me a slide edge
maybe maybe he gets in Bishop t2 it's
possible like he hmm
yeah that it's not it's not that great
it looks ridiculous for wide the whole
thing with his night on b1 and
everything but he gets in Bishop t2 and
probably holds this it's not very
comfortable but it's probably okay yeah
it was really really funny i blundered
dead rookie one here and it's still jack
kind of kind of tricky for a human
player to play 93 probably yeah the
computer is just so plus one here yeah
it's not it's not like I'm I'm lost me
but with good play with it sir it is a
tricky business yeah that was strong in
92 I didn't see that resource Knight f6
is so what the comps s and it approaches
the territory of being interesting 0.6
0.7 remarkable yeah i getcha form and
possibly a second porn because pieces
are so active but the position was not
as good as a thought I mean before that
yeah i was i was making the argument
that i could have gotten to this this
kind of thing with without being a piece
down but probably that's really not the
case i was to optimistic them and then
she i'm lost but it's still it's still a
check can still try to play play for
some tricks there 94 now is winning and
this is a draw remarkably enough yeah
could could fight on but yeah at the end
it's tricky yeah i actually thought that
I'm better here maybe with the apron and
obtained edition and then i tried to
offer a draw but he only had 40 seconds
but you cannot accept that is this not a
problem of the players it's a problem of
the time control okay it was an up and
down kind of struggle thanks for
watching